Dr. Anthony Foushee was interviewed on 60 Minutes
last night. He's the top infectious disease
doctor in the country, one of the top and most
trusted public health officials in the country.
And it's both interesting and really depressing
and tough to watch. I want to go through a few
of the things that Dr. Foushee said. It was a
wide ranging interview. This was an interesting
moment. Dr. Foushee was asked whether he
was surprised that Donald Trump personally
got coronavirus. Listen to what Dr. Foushee said.
Were you surprised that President Trump got sick?
Absolutely not.
I was worried that he was
going to get sick when I saw him in a completely
precarious situation of crowded no separation
between people and almost nobody wearing
a mask. When I saw that on TV. I said, oh,
my goodness. Nothing good can come out of that.
That's got to be a problem. And then sure enough,
it turned out to be a super spreader event.
So Foushee not only not surprised that Donald
Trump got Corona virus, but clearly and
unequivocally pointing out the White House
event for the nomination of Amy CONI Barrett. That
was a super spreader event. We know just of people
affiliated with Trump. Never mind. Rand dough's
in the audience. Chris Christie, Kellyanne Conway,
the president of Notre Dame, Trump, others caught
covered probably at that event. And Dr. Foushee,
he seems to just be sick of it at this
point. And you'll see why in a moment.
Just telling it like it is in this next clip.
And this is part of what Foushee is sick of.
You will see Dr. Foushee going for
a walk now with armed security.
Once an avid runner at 79, Dr. Foushee,
now power walks flanked by federal
agents. What's that all about? That's sad.
The very fact that a public health message to save
lives triggers such venom and animosity to me that
it results in real and credible threats to my life
and my safety. But it bothers me less than the
hassling of my wife and my children. They've been
threatened. Yeah, I mean, like, give me a break.
Have there been death threats against
you and your family, all of you?
You're not just me, but harassment and
harassment against the rest of the family.
What is wrong with this country? We have a
country where I'm not going to say half, but
20, 25, 30 percent of the country is arguably
institutionalized able. If that's a word and
it's not. But you understand what it means
up in their disconnect from reality and
they're backwards. I mean, it's directly
it's it's. To call it anti-social behavior. It
understates what it actually is. Threats to Dr.
Foushee and his wife and his daughters are there
leading public health officials in any other
country put in this degree of danger where they
need full time armed security. We are backwards
here. It's shameful. It's embarrassing. The
English language almost lacks its ability
to characterize this for what it is. And when you
look at what's going on in other countries, you're
starting to see leaders of both public health
and political leaders in other countries not even
tolerate the nonsense. We have interesting
clips over the last couple of weeks from
Ireland, from New Zealand, Australia and other
places in this country. The president is actually
fomenting this type of stuff against Dr. Foushee.
Very interestingly, one of the big conspiracies or
pejoratives applied to Dr. Foushee and Joe Biden
is they want to lock down everything forever.
They're old. They're just about lockdown's
kill the economy, Glocke it all down.
Even Dr. Foushee himself says he would be very
hesitant to recommend a national lockdown. And
this is important because Trump and the right
have been caricaturing him as wanting lockdown's
forever all the time. Foushee says quite simply
here, it's a last resort. It's not what I want.
How bad would things have to get for
you to advocate a national lockdown?
They'd have to get really, really bad.
First of all, the country is fatigued
with restrictions. So we want to use public
health measures not to get in the way
of opening the economy, but to being a safe
gateway to opening the economy. So instead of
having an opposition open up the economy, get
jobs back or shut down. No, put shutdown away
and say we're going to use public health measures
to help us safely get to where we want to go.
And of course, this is the problem. Half the
country is so busy saying we won't lock down,
which Foushee isn't suggesting that they're
ignoring the reality of the pandemic. They're
ignoring the things they can be doing
to prevent spread, including not having
big parties and events, particularly indoors,
masks, lots of other measures. But the point is,
this is not a guy itching to lock down the
country. And why would anyone be itching to
lock down the country? It's ridiculous.
Really important question that came up.
Has the White House been controlling
when and where? Dr. Fouche, you can
speak to the media. There have been rumors
that Dr. Foushee has not been allowed to
do certain shows. And Foushee says, yeah,
they have been limiting me. Take a look.
During this pandemic, has the White House been
controlling when you can speak with the media? You
know, I think you'd have to be honest to say yes.
I certainly have not been allowed to go on many,
many, many shows that have asked for me.
One of the most trusted voices in America. And yet
you're not there. You're not allowed to talk
with us. So can you understand the frustration
that maybe there's been a restriction on the
flow of information on transparency? You know,
I think there has been a restriction,
John, but it doesn't it isn't consistent.
The most trusted public official on the
topic of Corona virus, according to polling,
every poll Foushee, the most trusted on the issue
of Corona virus, blocked from speaking to people,
blocked from appearing on shows.
It's a sick country. And in fact,
Trump replied, you might remember this. Trump
replaced Foushee at his public events with
this doctor named Scott Atlas, who's a neuro
radiologist. Now understand neuro neuroradiology
is a specialty of radiology. What is a
radiologist? A radiologist is a doctor
who sits in a room. And I'm not demeaning what
radiologists do. I'm just telling you they don't
know about pandemics and infectious. This is a
writ much like you wouldn't go to a podiatrist
to deal with coronavirus. You wouldn't go to a
neuro radiologist, radiologist, look at X-rays,
MRI eyes, C.T. scans and other imaging to diagnose
conditions. When I went in for my appendectomy,
they did a C.T. scan. It was sent to a
radiologist who looked at the scan and said,
appendicitis, I'll take six hundred
dollars. Thank you very much.
That is what they do. Neuro radiology is a
subspecialty. Someone who looks at brain,
spine and neck images. Why is that person the
most prominent medical figure around Donald Trump
for dealing with a pandemic? Because he
says what Trump wants him to say. Masks
don't really work. He deleted that tweet. Let's
look at herd immunity. Let's open everything.
Nearly 100 Stanford immunologists signed a letter
calling out this guy. And this is who Trump
promotes as Dr. Foushee is blocked from being on
shows and needs armed security to go for a walk
with his wife. There has to be some reckoning
for this. Doesn't there does. I get. I mean, I
guess the reckoning is tons of people are getting
sick and dying relative to other countries. But
the consequences should affect the people who
ran the policy, not innocent people who through
this failed policy are catching the virus
and dying. It's it's absolutely disgusting.
And it only reinforces and highlights underlines
the urgency of removing Joe Biden I'm sorry,
removing Donald Trump and removing these doctors
and putting in Joe Biden. I voted this weekend.
You can find video of me voting all perfectly
beautiful legal video on my Instagram at David
Pakman. Let me know if you voted either there
or you can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.